[Music]
in ultimate trol news submitted by hobo
Yonkers Belle Delphine fans got upset
after she trolled them with unsexy
pornhub video I seen this one
Belle Delphine well she's a cosplayer
yes how come all white cosplayers try to
look Asian that's trying to play a
character cuz your friends are anime I
think but why do they have to try to
look Asian and why can't they just go
straight to the character oh yeah yeah
try to do it Asian izing thing and then
do a turd no well isn't that because
enemy mainly like Asian characters they
don't look very Asian the Sailor moons
blonde just Dragonball I know that's not
even but like that's how she just can be
finished on what agent I look like this
no in the anime world now can you do
with their hands I'm not too sure if
we're all the same
do it like do it with their fingers
sighs I can make sure you're taught you
can't do it can you do like this is the
enemy I know but can you do like this
you know anime eyes like this like this
I always talk about Bart can you ask me
to do look like
dare you just [ __ ] do that and try to
carry a conversation like this you
looked at it [ __ ] napkin who did that
job that's not the most important thing
that happened though anime eyes is the
most important thing that happens the
anime eyes look like aviators why are
they so windowed cheap cuz they're cute
like bigger eyes is super cute it's more
expression you can do it yeah yeah yeah
like you know how deers have big-ass
eyes and then they're like really pretty
and cute yeah
alright so Belle Duffy
she is very popular on Instagram she has
3.6 million followers
katia her whole thing on her Instagram
is to post pose like really like
scantily clad and softcore porn pretty
much softcore porn that's her whole
thing and so she does have a patreon
where she says that there's not safe for
work photos that she post there but she
posted this and she had these pasty that
say [ __ ] me and the caption says if this
photo gets 1 million likes I'll actually
make a pornhub account the time has
officially come take your friends /
dad's to help out cuz you posted this on
Father's Day
oh ok that make sense a tag your friends
so this photo got almost 2 million likes
so people are like dude likes
she's pretty big nobody most people's
likes don't hit their subscribe cuz they
got fake followers it's just it's cuz
she's so relatable she's relatable to
men exactly yep I have fishnets just
like her like I know her alright so then
it's a character too like this was also
cosplay
that's like her thing she she just looks
like this I don't know which what the
ears thing yeah that's what I'm thinking
she's relatable cat I think your
neighborhood cat she's a [ __ ] cat can't
you see down the street yeah me like
that though where they're like cats and
[ __ ] oh no ears look how the [ __ ]
cute I want to tell still I like when
girls have the ears thing on their
[ __ ] hair wouldn't call it though why
do you like it could he look like
animals
yeah what is it about looking like an
animal that looks sexy I mean like when
girls wear cheetah print [ __ ] sexy right
I don't know that's just whether they
were in tight [ __ ] yeah is it the
cheetah print or is it thank you I've
never seen you slithering skin both
baggy cheetah print jeans
wears a fur coat she's hot - mm-hmm
a hot girl wears anything she's hot oh
that's true yeah pretty much yeah she
could wear a [ __ ] elephant trunk
she's hot
what if she's not wearing anything is
she hot then nah nah yeah naked is not
hot sure all right so see she did
finally create her pornhub account like
a couple days later after people are
like deliver [ __ ] we gave you your legs
so then she did and so all these
thumbnails here they all look really
seductive and so some of the titles say
Belle Delphine gets huge dripping
[ __ ] I know I'm Belle Delphine gets
huge a load blown on her and then Bella
theme plz doggy style and then PewDiePie
goes all the way inside philadelphi look
at all those thumbs down though I know
because you click the load one well this
is a screenshot of the video oh sorry
that's the one I would have picked what
about you guys so the PewDiePie one it
was just her eating a picture of
PewDiePie so he went inside she was just
rolling in the that really did trolling
how'd she troll us with the load one
like waiting next to a computer waiting
for it to load I mean guys would still
bus tonight and be like jokes on you i
still can jojo's like i still jerked off
mouse still can't jokes on you it worked
on me anyway she's not doing anything
different cuz like her whole thing like
she'll be like she has like her hands
down her panties and be like oh I'm
looking for my keys kind of [ __ ] like if
she does that anyway her father
should've been surprising like this is
what she does I think what they're
expecting if they're if she's gonna be
on par where it's just finally yeah like
a real porno and boarhog like YouTube
like there might be other users that
just go what the [ __ ] is this
yeah I wanted some [ __ ] exactly
people oh here's another one so that
green pipe you dripping cream pie
classic what are the commenters on
pornhub saying are there any comments I
think there are we want Gio come on come
on you know come on don't know I just
look at the picture and then I look at
the video I get off and I'm out
you never scroll down and you're like I
want to look at some of these comments
yeah no I don't like in the bottom the
pornhub sphere yeah no they're pretty uh
yeah disgusting oh you've heard them
yeah they go they go far they go super
far but they're also they're there
they're supportive and they're nicer Oh
like ooh I would I would face there are
like you can watch a video of a girl
getting gay main and then you see like a
bunch of people underneath it and
they're like I wish this was me and that
has 24 thumbs up yeah that's the thing
like there's some but they which
obviously it's like role-playing but
they like you know having sex with my
stepsister whatever and then the people
in the console like I would definitely
be my stepsister Wow it's like wait
that's why they make roleplay like
that's why they make it it's crazy
that's really that's really think about
think about the hot mom thing it's like
oh I'm banging my friend's hot mom
that's every single video is written one
that isn't that the fans here are they
like like [ __ ] we're gonna subscribe
cuz you are a troll [ __ ] exactly so
this one's this one love it would you
like to read this comment we got we need
to unfollow her all and unlike
everything we did retake the cloud we
gave her and force her into making
actual pool that's what people been into
ever since she farted put her in a cloud
drought and feed it to her as a reward
like a little pit when she's actually
giving us what we wanted wow that person
should divorce her and support yeah if
we arrested that guy the world would be
a better place
I agree I bet you as a twelve-year-old
probably 46 year old no I completely
agree I feel like this is how people
start their write stuff like this and
then they start blaming the chick for
not giving the guy what he wants and he
eventually goes into those crazy
[ __ ] out write those manifestos
and end up like
shooting [ __ ] oh yeah like that Santa
Barbara guys yeah I think that's the
start of it he was mad because he
couldn't get [ __ ] I love being so
pissed you go home she finally made a
porn on account you pull it up any like
man we all need a force hurt like who so
much of a [ __ ] he is it's not I it's
all like you guys with me because I'm a
[ __ ] like I need my help I'm still
gonna stay subscribe yeah they're the
kind of guys that kidnapped girls in bus
to train on them this other one says
Belle Delphine you will rue this day the
day you crushed all the 12 and 13 year
old boys who waited a week for your
videos you posted horrible content and
you will pay all the gamers are coming
together to find you Belle you've got a
pal a bounty wanted dead or alive be
warned don't mess with the gamers you
mate you may have just started
Woolworths that major don't mess with
the game what do you say gamers okay
that made told don't mess with the
gamers is something you say before you
get your ass completely handed to you
[Laughter]
the gamers and edges woke up here in the
hospital hey what happened if I said
don't mess with the gamers is there no
body cast game no but some people sound
pretty serious like this one has 188
likes oh god it looks like this Wow damn
dude that's how [ __ ] thirsty they are
but belt I actually was hoping for a
change in my life something to make me
feel again and yet you ruined me as a
person as an individual I am hurt by
this you scarred me for life I actually
thought that you would be the better
person and drop the vids my dude yet you
back stabbed us gamers that accepted you
into us gamers and society how dare you
cosplay like some of our equals we don't
accept you as an eagle or a gamer you
have been shamed beyond recognition you
aren't our sister in arms anymore just
leave this place that we call home and
never show your face again or you will
hurt us more than then you intended
leave now please or I will have to do
something on my own not to hurt you but
to protect my brothers that have been
hurt duty [ __ ] is going so I'm sure
Azarath Longfellow is this guy I think
these are troll this is a response to
like if the Red Cross promised they're
gonna donate water to some sort of
natural disaster and then they take it
away then you're like I can't believe
you I depended on this there's gonna be
life changing now we're all gonna die
but it's just a girl not doing porn at
least you're learning activism alright
sure that's pretty nice this is what the
gamers are pushing for this is what
they're trying to be like picket fence
to pay fines for it we want to see she
blows it to all of these videos but yeah
good for her man that shit's pretty
funny these are the kind of guys that
pay for a striptease and think they're
actually gonna see something and then
it's like oh [ __ ] I didn't see anything
like it's called a striptease you
[ __ ] idiot they're gonna take their
virginity away yeah like what you're
telling me you're not gonna take my
Virginia Lee or the girl whispers in his
ear that he's cute and then he keeps
coming back because he thinks he likes
something connection it's the best the
titles are really what sold it like
titles all the porno videos like that's
will probably had them like every single
one was a troll like yeah alright maybe
the next one the third was for sure they
gotta watch every single like and then
they'd probably watch it till the end to
like okay she's doing a bit here but
she's gonna take the cream pie at the
end I know slow the guy's gotta be
hiding somewhere there's five seconds
left to the video I know it's gonna
happen oh that's so funny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]